It turns out that even the
most random day of you life
might follow a global pattern.
Anthony here for DNews.
Think about your weekend.
You head out to hang
out or do errands.
Do you think much about
the route that you take.
You probably think you do
things in a very patterned
or a totally random way.
But research says,
you're probably
following the same
pattern whether you're
thinking about it or not.
There's an order to your day
that you're not even aware of.
And it's called the Levy Walk.
The Levy Walk describes a
pattern of hunting in animals.
And if you take a
look at a couple,
they're not exactly the same.
Though you can see
a clear pattern.
And the idea is
this, animals when
hunting make these random
clustered movements to find
food in a small space.
And then when they
decide they probably
exhausted their possibilities
in an area, they just bolt.
Tearing off in one random
direction for a while
and then clustering again.
It's been found
in birds and bees,
it's been found in land mammals,
and sharks, and spiders,
and even bacteria.
It seems to be
the go to strategy
for just about any
living thing out there
that needs to find food
in its environment.
But it's been thought that
early humans might not
have fallen into
the Levy pattern.
That because of our higher
cognitive ability and or more
advanced memories,
we'd of somehow
been more systematic
in our searches.
So Anthropologist David Raichlen
at the University of Arizona
decided to test that.
He asked members of the Hadza,
a group of hunter gatherers
in Tanzania, to wear GPS
loggers on their arms.
The Hadza gather 95% of
their food in the wild.
They hunt warthogs, and
they eat tubers, and greens.
But by watching how they
moved for about a year,
Raichlen found that
regardless of how
they were getting their food
foraging, or hunting they
followed the Levy pattern
about half the time.
And it makes sense
up to a point,
you use up the resources
of a small area.
And then you take
off for a new one.
But why move so far?
Why hasn't a tribe like
the Hadza developed
a more ordered or
sophisticated system?
Is there really
even significance
or is the Levy pattern
one of those things that's
just random enough that we
can fit it into most places?
Now, Raichlen said that we can
see the Levy pattern in more
of our everyday
lives then we think.
We might have even built
our cities around it.
For instance, I do
most of my errands
or hanging out in
my neighborhood
within a short distance
of my apartment.
And then I shoot off for a while
in one direction towards work.
2007 study showed that
statistically people walking
around a city center, College
campus, theme park, shopping
mall, basically any walk around
10 kilometers or shorter,
tends to follow a Levy pattern.
So the goal now is to figure
out if a Levy pattern really
is as ingrained
in us as it seems.
And if so, why?
Why do we set out
completely randomly
and then naturally
follow this pattern?
And now that you know about it,
can you see it in your life?
Let me know down below and
subscribe to more DNews.